er wollte einst schauspieler werden und
fand dann seine rolle als pfarrer sieber
etwas spektakel gehört zu seinen
auftritten so sicher wie das amen in der
kirche
das ist wie er nach aufwand der echte
sieber hat für die obdachlosen
weihnachtsfeier ein doodle engagiert das
noble hotel marriott in zürich spendet
rund 600 anständigen ein üppiges buffet
für notleidende macht ernst sieber seit
jahrzehnten weit mehr als nur den
nikolaus zu spielen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wie viel ernst steckt eigentlich hinter
diesem sieber der als pfarrer so
fröhlich sein kann
[Musik]
hier endete beinahe das leben des
bekanntesten pfarrers der schweiz
im juni 2012 verlor ernst sieber am
steuer plötzlich das bewusstsein
sein wagen prallte mit voller wucht in
eine strassenlaterne beim zürcher
triemli
[Musik]
mit sechs gebrochenen rippen wurde der
85 jährige ins spital eingeliefert
körperlich sei er schnell wieder gesund
gewesen aber die psychische verarbeitung
habe lange gedauert sagt der seelsorger
die ursache für seinen schwächeanfall
bleibt bis heute ein rätsel das
schwierig zu beantworten will
im himmel muss es so schön ist das land
aber noch geht
wir haben mit den ruf gabe und mit der
möglichkeit die mauer fahre ich mir
jeden tag wunderlich was hübsch sie
etwas nun passiert letzten endes ist es
ja genau da sie nach dem unfall gab
ernst sieber seinen fahrausweis
freiwillig ab unfreiwillig musste er den
fahrausweis bereits fünfmal abgeben weil
er zu schnell unterwegs war mit seinem
zwölf stundenkilometer gefährt kann ihn
das nicht mehr passieren aber auch mit
dem elektromobil hält er sich nicht
immer ganz an die verkehrsregeln
also ja bedrohung der schiffe mit andern
ist geht das nicht mehr mit freude aber
wenig gekommen war wie drüben
für längere distanzen lässt sich heute
der evangelische kirchen man chauffieren
sein fahrer werner graf hat eine bewegte
lebensgeschichte
er war ganz unten angekommen also dem
fahrer kennen lernte ernst sieber hat
schon vielen menschen geholfen sie zu
freunden gemacht
einer von ihnen heißt django zu dem die
beiden unterwegs sind
der ehemalige obdachlose ist an krebs
erkrankt er liegt in einem sterbehospiz
in der nähe von ulm
was für eine überraschung noch tage
zuvor konnte der schwer kranke keinen
schritt mehr gehen
der besuch des pfarrers hat ihm neue
lebenskraft gegeben
[Musik]
als deutscher staatsangehöriger ist
django in seinem heimatland versichert
und er wird deshalb auch hier
medizinisch versorgt er befindet sich im
hospizhaus maria in biberach in baden
württemberg auch django lebte jahrelang
in zürich auf der straße bis er vom
pfarrer in einer seiner sozialen
einrichtungen aufgenommen wurde
als dank dafür bot der ernst sieber
seine dienste als leibwächter an der
kirchenmann nahm das angebot an
obwohl er eigentlich gar keinen
bodyguard gebraucht hätte wirklich warme
weiß mesum entstanden ist dass gottes
lang tätig und der tank 1 5 liebe
gibt 3715 league weit kommen
wir warten natürlich bis jetzt schon
wieder kommt weil er eine hilfe ist man
kann schon sagen vom lieben gott
gebracht
[Musik]
ja und jetzt hoffen jedoch ganz einfach
dass das wieder gut wie besser wählt im
namen vom lieben gott wird das geschehen
gut groß mit und meine lieben freunde
wir bleiben freunde doch ist der himmel
die uns babyspeck toni kroos nach die
flotte dann mit der sterne ganz legal
[Musik]
ernst sieber will den unheilbar kranken
zu sich in die schweiz holen um ihn
während seiner letzten zeit zu begleiten
noch sind die bürokratischen hürden
nicht überwunden
[Musik]
selbst mit seinen 85 jahren gönnt er
sich nur selten etwas ruhe
am abend hat er wieder etwas los
das ist seine tochter ilona weber hat
vier leibliche und adoptierte kinder
lola leitet den spießhof im
schaffhausischen ramsen die soziale
institution baute ernst sieber in den
90er jahren ruft der spießhof ist ein
selbsthilfe darf für menschen in not die
lernen wieder fuß zu fassen
die bewohnerin maria hat heute
geburtstag
elena und ihr vater stehen sich sehr
nahe sind sehr viel wenn ich sehr
dankbar bin
wir danken für die suppe mit danke dem
modell aber hat geburtstag feiert und
ptv hat jesus christus für den archiv
auch sie weiß ehefrau sonja nimmt am
geburtstagsfest teil
die ehemalige opernsängerin ist mit dem
pfarrer seit 50 jahren liiert
dann ist das natürlich
[Musik]
[Applaus]
gott sei dank habe so viele eltern
trainerin wenn er die nbc also die
vaudois die zehen gesehen
die fr musikgruppen soll macht wo man
steht und frauenfußball wm hat das muss
ja meistens außer wann hört ja wenn wir
dafür dass ich so was gibt's ja ja und
hier muss also wird der song geben muss
und getauft was ist eine sonne grund
einer monarchie
also jahrelang um zuverlässigkeit
[Musik]
aber ich muss mir sagte was dann
gekommen kochen kann
[Musik]
sieber als stimmungskanone ein
vertrautes bild für alle die mit ihm zu
tun haben
[Applaus]
dies teilt auch comedians oder an der
information der bühne steht dann ist das
richtig 20 minuten
christoph zink ist seit zwei jahren
gesamtleiter der stiftung pfarrer sieber
in sieben sozial betrieben mit
unterschiedlichen aufgaben arbeiten
heute rund 170 mitarbeiter sie betreuen
aids kranke obdachlose und menschen mit
psychischen beeinträchtigungen früher
flossen alleine wegen seiner
charismatischen persönlichkeit
spendengelder in millionenhöhe
ob als svp nationalrat in den 90er
jahren oder als prediger sieber war ein
meister der inszenierung seien sozial
imperium wuchs und wuchs
dann kam das jahr 2004 und mit ihm die
krise der stiftungsrat teilte in einer
pressekonferenz mit dass die sozialwerke
kurz vor dem bankrott stünden die
verantwortung musste der pfarrer tragen
ihm wurde fehlende transparenz
vorgeworfen christoph zenk arbeitete
damals noch nicht für die sozialwerke
er weiß jedoch dass sich sieber kaum
finanzen kümmert sie sind ja im taxi und
diesem umsatzniveau relativ frei mit den
finanzen kommen sind und dann mit jedem
mit jeder kunde transaktion einmal
einige setzen obwohl diese art von film
zu film fesselt die jesus seine jünger
schafft euro gemacht hat aber sich nicht
unbedingt iris klein schafft finanzen
ich danke das war doch eigentlich
überfällig und da bin ich mir bewusst
wehrheim auktion abhält xs ging es
derweil um staub
also ich blieb der ruf gab frontteil
wird zu machen
dankbar dass es geht wo finanzen technik
bringen
geht wählen hätte heute durch seine
soziale betriebe weiß er dass sein
lebenswerk wieder schwarze zahlen
schreibt
gerettet wurde die stiftung durch eine
anonyme spende von einer million franken
verbunden allerdings mit auflagen
verlangt wurden klare führungsstrukturen
zudem musste der pfarrer aus dem
stiftungsrat austreten
das ist natürlich für ihn verliebt sich
wohnen
darunter leidet also dass eine narbe
hinterlasse spielcasino immer wieder
sichtbar werden
und wenn er sich auch sehr ungleich
behandelt fühlt das kann man so oder so
weg um die sensibilität für öfter als
früher zieht er sich heute in sein
atelier am sihlsee zurück über seine
sensible und verletzliche seite spricht
er nicht gerne und wenn dann nur
ansatzweise
darunter sind auffällig dass ich viele
fröhlich machen
[Musik]
das innerste eines menschen wird dort
berührt wo seine wurzeln liegen
da findet er halt fahrer sievers
kraftort liegt auf dem herzl oberhalb
des zürichsees als bub jahre vor seinem
theologiestudium arbeitete er hier unter
dieser linke als bauern knechte sind in
der liga gut kleidet und sisi wir im
himmel durch heimische heimat und die
dänischen hof
das ist unwahrscheinlich früher grob
blüht
dass sie für mich grundlage von ihm da
sie und natürlich dann kommt
entscheidend die deutschen acht knöpfe
gülle zwischen humus mit gottes sage
dann im mini wurzel an geistiger sind
die befunde erde himmel gutes niveau
[Musik]
in bitterkalten nächten streift er ab
und an mit mitarbeitern durch zürichs
einsame gassen
sie sind auf der suche nach obdachlosen
die sich unter büsche verkriechen oder
anderswo und erfrieren könnten
manchmal finden sie nur deren
habseligkeiten
[Musik]
das ist peter die beiden kennen sich
seit jahren
der pfarrer gibt ihm ein 5 franken stück
gerne würde peter seine hilfe anbieten
ihm ein warmes bett geben aber er lehnt
ab
er will sich nur in einer bar etwas
aufwärmen mal bis goethe stets fuß bus
wo es auch platz für peter hätte im
sattelschlepper stehen betten für
obdachlose zur verfügung
freiwillige mitarbeiterinnen sorgen für
warmes essen
auch im geheizten vorzelt gibt es
schlafmöglichkeiten platz hat es für
insgesamt 35 hilfsbedürftige persönlich
[Musik]
das hatte mehr wie 40
mit der held genau belegt dass ich ja
die solidargemeinschaft wo entscheidend
ist dass es ist seine sie aufbauend
wirkt herum es aber wieder den griffel
und da bliebe gewinner an und wirken
samstag ist für alle da sind
[Musik]
pfarrer ernst sieber wärmt die herzen
von notleidenden durch taten
ein bisschen schon gehört auch dazu
da die
[Musik]
dass sie nur
bon kredit